avec l'idée d'une preuve de vaccination
pour voyager vient aussi l'idée d'exiger
cette vaccination pour aller au travail
on en parle de tout avec l'avocate
marianne commandons bonsoir bonsoir une
entreprise peut-elle obliger ses
employés à se faire vacciner en fait
l'employeur toujours le droit de refuser
le vaccin et le vaccin c'est un soin et
selon code civil de ça prend un
consentement libre et éclairé pour
donner un soin à n'importe quel individu
donc c'est un choix personnel c'est un
choix qui relève de la vie privée
à moins que le gouvernement voudrait
être appliqué l'article 123 de la loi
sur la santé publique et d'ordonner que
tous les québécois se fassent vacciner
ou encore qu'une partie des québécois
plus à risque se fassent vacciner ce
qu'ils ont dit que pour l'instant
n'était pas dans les quatre n'était pas
dans les objectifs donc l'esl employant
ensuite déterminer comment il va gérer
la vaccination dans son milieu de
travail et ses claques et certains
employeurs qui ont connu des
conséquences dévastatrices de l'aco vide
qui vont vouloir rencontrer le caisse de
l'exigence professionnelle justifiée
dont passons aux travailleurs qui sont
en zone rouge dans les 6 h et celle des
ou encore dans les hôpitaux
ben évidemment le risque de contracter
le virus est d'avoir des conséquences
graves sont beaucoup plus grandes en ces
endroits leur ai donc les employeurs
pourront ainsi rencontre se tester leur
c'est un test assez lourd dans
l'exigence professionnelle justifier que
il faut que la personne soit vaccinée
pour être dans ce postulat si la
personne refuse de des vaccinés ce
qu'elle a toujours le droit
alors là l'emploi on va devoir la
déplacer la place et un autre endroit
et s'il n'a pas de poste il pourra la
congédie création administrative mais ça
c'est si on est sur un poste qui à cette
exigence très officielle dont vous
parlez mais un employé qui dit moi je ne
veux pas me faire vacciner
l'employeur peut-il dire à cet employé
bête tu restes en télétravail ou goethe
affecte à une autre fonction
mme harvey abarth ou du moment que
l'employeur pour exiger
la vaccination chez un employé pour un
poste de neil donc envoyait toujours le
droit de refuser il y aurait jamais
personne qui veut l'obliger à moins
qu'on leur en afrique la loi sur la
santé publique
mais à partir de ce moment là la voyant
peut dire je rencontre le test de la
charte de l'exigence professionnelle
justifié et pour ce poste là si tu
refuses de faire vacciner une europe
pourra pas aller travailler dans ce
poste-là
parce que j'étais aux deux postes que tu
peux aller où il n'y a pas de danger ou
tel aux deux postes
mais ça peut mener aussi un peu de
postes disponibles ça pourrait amener un
con j'étais en sera-t-il parce qu on
touche ici aux droits et obligations des
travailleurs mais on touche aussi aux
droits et libertés des personnes tout à
fait tout à fait possible violation à
l'intégrité un vaccin la salle et des
idées c'est ça ton dans la vie privée
des gens un choix qui est volontaire qui
est personnel et donc évidemment un
certain moment il faut que l'envoyant
rencontre c'est ce critère là un peu
comme un employé qui doit par exemple à
son emploi soulever des charges de 106
500 livres à répétition l'avoir va
pouvoir vérifier si la personne ont la
capacité musculo squelettiques pour
soulever ces chargeurs et exiger un
certificat médical comme quoi qui peut
le faire pour être embauché dans un tel
poste avec la même chose pour la
vaccination pour les postes qui sont
hautement a réussi et qui ont subi le
des conséquences très importantes le
pensons chcd le nom de des sexes a causé
avec une clientèle vulnérable ses décors
très précis mais un enfant pourra pas du
tout le monde entreprises pour tous mes
employés tout le monde doit être vacciné
travailler mais je lis rencontreront
paul piste mais un employeur peut
encourager fortement jusqu'où il peut
aller à encourager ses employés sport
etc ce n'est même plus les encourager en
plus comme le gouvernement du québec le
fil dans ses publicités mais il doit
donner le pour et le contre et
l'ensemble d'information on veut que les
employés puissent faire un choix éclairé
donc il faut que autant les éléments
positifs et négatifs de la vaccination
c'est celle important le qu'ils aient
toutes les formations pour prendre une
bonne décision
est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de
la vaccination sur le lieu de travail
il va y avoir des entreprises qui vont
contre
commencé à offrir la vaccination à leurs
employés comment on va comment on doit
baliser sa part tient peu comme la
vaccination qu'on connaît leur milieu de
travail pour la grille qui existait
depuis longue date
il ya déjà eu des réclamations à
seignosse esprits pour avoir été vacciné
pas avoir subi des conséquences de
vaccination à partir du moment que c'est
un choix qui est personnel voulons taxe
est très clair que consentement été
donné et que la personne n'avait le
droit de refuser le vaccin à ce
moment-là ça pourra pas être reconnu
comme étant un accident du travail ou de
maladie professionnelle et donc c'est
important que l'employeur s'assure qu'il
ya un consentement écrit les briques les
ris avec toute l'information sur le
vaccin que la personne qu'on sent par
écrit avec sa signature et doit aussi et
idéalement une politique de vaccination
sont comment ils vont procéder
ok c'est très clair marien de train
bordeaux merci beaucoup merci à vous
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d